whoo Thanks hi everyone I hope you're
having a wonderful joyous conf
I would like to introduce the lovely
members of the tc39 who are joining us
today to answer some questions it would
be great if you could each introduce
yourselves and to mention who you're
representing on the tc39 hi I'm Matthias
and I work on v8 at Google I'm Aki and I
work at PayPal I'm Justin Rijal I work
for Google I'm also one of the core
contributors to Babel I'm Keith circle
and I work for a github hi I'm Matt eco
I was all work at Google as web
developer relations team I'm Lin Clark I
work at Mozilla and repop rocky I work
at Bloomberg Church NIDA white also at
Mozilla I am Leo I work at Baku and
maintainer of test to 16 now we've got a
lot of really fantastic people
representing a diverse number of
companies and groups but in fact there's
even more people here there among you we
have a number of tc39 members who are
not on stage if they could just stand up
and wave hello yeah yeah so we if Eric
WA if we don't manage to get to your
question please come and see us after
this panel and we'd love to talk to you
we'll be hanging around the community
lounge just behind the Google booth
everyone knows where the community
lounge so come say hi so without further
ado let's get started with a panel and
I'm gonna start with a question that the
jeaious conf you team had for us which
is date parse they had an issue with the
web site in that iOS wouldn't scroll
down to the right spot and the question
is date departs who did it wrong v8 or
Chrome I can take that one so I
encourage everyone in the room to go to
the dev tools console maybe after his
talk and try out date bars one octopus
2018 it works in Chrome it works in JSC
and Safari but nowhere else and it turns
out that based on the spec everyone is
right like there are certain date for
that are guaranteed to work and all
browsers according to the spec at least
but when the format it's not matched
then it's basically up to the
implementation so that's why some
implementations return man and others
actually still try to parse the date
thank you so before we go any further
let's talk about what we're actually
doing so Matias just gave us a great
explanation about the what the spec is
it's not an implementation but it sort
of tells us how to implement a
JavaScript engine so let's just talk
about what the tc39 is actually doing
and what a spec is does anyone want to
talk about what the process is or how to
see 39 works
no how it's easy 39 works and I'll let
someone else to explain the stages of
the process but we are a committee of
delegates who are representing members
in Accra International we get together
every two months and we usually meet for
three days we discuss what proposals are
up we talk about the impact of language
we discuss you know what what changes
need to be made and we operate on
consensus which means that we all have
to agree for something to move forward
which is pretty unique in programming
language standards so that's kind of
like the basic gist of what tc39
is and does somebody else won't go
through the proposal process sure so
there's four stages stage 0 is like a
pseudo stage that is just a proposal
exists State one is that the committee
has considered that this is a problem
space that we want to continue to
explore and find a solution for Stage
two is that there's a draft
specification so there is some spec text
that identifies what the behavior should
be
Stage three says that there's going
there
should be significant in the filled
implementations in other words some
browsers or other engines should have
implemented this feature and stage 4
means that it's ready for to land in the
spec every year we make a cut of all of
the stage 4 features that land on a our
stage 4 by a particular date which I
think is somewhere around March and by
around June time that spec for that year
is released so we're close to releasing
es 2018 which will have several stage 4
features that were Stage four back in
January if I if I can add to that also
I'm a somewhat newer member of this
process and I think it's important to
mention that the meeting happens those
three day meetings every two months
happens where we discuss like like stage
advancement and consensus sneaking stuff
but actual conversation about how the
spec should be spec and how the text
should be written happens all the time
this is not like every two months we
pick up like right two months ago
wait where did we left off it's not it's
usually just the suite the meetings that
we have three days or more like okay
here's what has been happening on github
on the tc39 organization for two months
let's decide on how to move forward
great so we had a couple of community
questions about like how the specking
process works and one person asked is
javascript evolving at the right speed
are new features being sufficiently
integrated with other new and existing
features yes I think one one proposal
that might be a really great one to sort
of illustrate how this works is the
class proposal and we also had a couple
of questions to maybe help shape this so
one person asked what's going on with
the private method we've got the hash
sign which is used to express private
most other languages use the private key
word how do we come up to this point
that we're using the hash sign okay so
when we consider private we have to
consider two parts there's private
access which allows you to get the
private property off of an object and
then there is the private declaration
the reason we came upon this decision is
because every other language that has
private is also statically typed so you
can figure out exactly what the property
is based on the object it's being called
on for JavaScript we don't have that
we've no way of knowing what the object
is or whether it's supposed to be a
private property or a public property
based on just the base reference that
this dot object up whatever so we have
to have a different signal to
distinguish private property access from
public property access that's how we
came upon the dot hash whatever the
property name is for accessing the
properties and then to mirror access we
decided that the declaration should also
include the hash symbol so it makes it
very clear upfront that this is the part
of the name that the way that you access
ed is you pretend that the hash is just
part of the name so if it's hash prop
you access it by this dot hash prop so
it's kind of like you think about it as
if the hash is just the name not that
it's actually distinguishes the private
modifier key or anything else nice and
the private class field was being
proposed as a single proposal however
there were several other class related
proposals that were being proposed at
the same time such as public fields how
was the communication across those
proposals we do a lot of work to make
sure these two features are synchronized
we actually split them and then merge
them and then split them and merge them
again between public and private and
instance and static properties just
trying to figure out all the different
issues that could have happened with
either of them and then once we settled
upon the semantics that we were happy
with we've merged them all again awesome
so I think a natural question that would
follow this like we've got this hash
symbol now but this could be confusing
to newcomers and another person has
asked us over Twitter with these new
operators and features being added to
JavaScript are we at risk for becoming
too cryptic syntax wise for new
developers
I'm very much in favor of them but web
development is being very approachable
as a big boon I guess say it's something
that does come up in the meetings it's
referred to as the syntax budget that
there's only so much syntax you can add
to a language before it just becomes a
ASCII gibberish so it is very much a
concern and everybody pays a lot of
attention to it and we try to make all
of these proposals fit together as a
whole and this is also why syntax
proposals are different from just new
API methods on like array.prototype or
something like that because those are
things you can look up and then you
already know how to call a function or
how to call a method on our array for
example but whenever there's new syntax
that that imposes a burden on developers
to actually learn to recognize this new
syntax and all its meanings so syntax is
more complicated to learn as a newcomer
than it is to just call another method
so maybe this is also a good point for
another note on the process one thing we
are trying as a middle ground between
design by committee either achieving
nothing because results in constant
deadlock or achieving sort of okay I get
mine future my future and so you get
yours and we get this explosion of
features that maybe nobody really needs
we have the so-called champions model so
all proposals are have one or more
champions who work on really developing
the the feature and present it to the
committee and by and large the committee
overall does not do the design it needs
to achieve consensus but it's not like
all everybody gets to chime in and say
but I want this tweak in and this syntax
should be slightly different and then
I'm happy and in practice that works out
fairly well to achieve a manageable
complexity budget another question
that's going around like the general
development of how javascript is
designed is a question around what is
Java scripts identity like are we moving
towards other non strong
typed programming languages for example
object-oriented concepts like es6
classes or more functional and this also
is tied to like where are we going as a
goal in JavaScript like what are we
aiming for I think I believe JavaScript
has of like very strong notation on them
all the behaviors they it does around
the types they are well defined in
JavaScript but I think like that being a
dynamic type language is one of the
highlights of JavaScript itself I don't
see this thing happening for now I don't
expect this happening tc39
I think this is a highlight and we
should like consider all the advantages
from using from a dynamic language in a
typed language of are fine but we are on
the right place here I also think that
this is just some extent of false
distinction modern more modern languages
like swift or West are really heavily
influenced by both object orientation
and functional design patterns and you
really take the best of these worlds and
make a well-designed of all languages
that allows people to express their
their logic in ways where it makes sense
instead of having to cram it into some
notion of pure building so one of the
one topic that came up quite a bit on
Twitter was of course about types but it
was also about typescripts reason ml
pure script and Babel these are all
things that transpile to JavaScript so
javascript isn't the isn't necessarily
pure but do these other languages that
adopt different paradigms and what
JavaScript have how much does this
influence our work on the language in
general I think it's great to have all
of these language
even if it are like targeting JavaScript
I believe they allow the community to
bring feedback as these languages are
low like some sandboxing we cannot do
directly on JavaScript and we can play
with this languages we feature that we
want and we can make like proof that
they are really necessary if we want to
bring this to JavaScript from my
experience there's already brought a lot
of nice interesting features that we
already have today in JavaScript and I
really appreciate that and maybe on one
of the fields where there is a lot of
experimentation in compiled to J's
languages
there's types there are obviously
typescript and flow but also quite a few
other languages that add types to
JavaScript or Java Script like languages
and so the question comes up why aren't
we adding types to the language itself
and the reason is quite simply we don't
believe that there anybody has come up
with a design that works well enough for
JavaScript and it is really universal
enough that we are comfortable taking up
the huge design space if really you add
types to language once you don't do that
multiple times so this is a huge
decision and so it's fantastic that we
we have this ecosystem of compiled to
Drai's languages that can do all the
experimentation they want and people can
decide to pave the cow paths on this and
hopefully eventually will converge on a
design where we feel like yes this
really fits the language this is what we
should add to the standard itself and we
have we also have some people who are
working within the Muslim community
group it would be really great to hear
about what's the relationship between
JavaScript and wasum as compiled targets
so one of the nice things we were
talking about the Explo
of features and JavaScript earlier one
of the nice things about having
webassembly as a compliment to
javascript is that for some of the
features that don't make sense in
JavaScript you can actually use web
assembly as the home for that feature
where it might make more sense and so
I'd say that web assembly and JavaScript
really are complementary as compiled
targets and not as some people think
competitors and this also effects types
again directly because for good
interaction with web assembly that isn't
extremely low-level on the linear memory
as an exchange level you want to have
the ability to talk about the type
system from both sites and there are
efforts around making that possible they
don't actually need syntax for those
types which might be a bit surprising at
first this is something where over the
next few months or so certainly within
this year they were we will have more
things to show one thing we got
requested from the audience via Twitter
is that we talked more closely into the
mic so that's right
okay so people have also been asking
some things that are just ideas about
what what the future of JavaScript could
be like and one person's asked can we
have something like a module keyword
that makes bundling a first-class
citizen of JavaScript and allow a single
JS file to expose multiple interface
multiple modules as an interface
yeah come see me because I have a
proposal in the works for that so yes we
can't have that
so moving and moving on to another topic
so over the last year we sort of had a
bit of a situation and someone asks can
you share your perspectives on flatten
versus smoosh debate I can give some
history here so what happens is that
there was a proposal to add flatten and
flat map to the array prototype and and
it got to stage three and Mozilla
lamented it and sort of to ship it in
Firefox nightly they realized that it
was actually breaking certain webpages
they relied on this particular
implementation not being there so of
course this is kind of the worst thing
that can happen to a proposal like when
we ship it we don't want to break the
web this is not acceptable so Mozilla
unshifted but then we had to go back to
the drawing board and we knew we had to
change the proposal in some way and in
this case because the name itself was
the problem it was specifically for flat
and we had to rename it somehow and then
the proposal author decided to send a
joke boo request to his proposal
renaming it to smoosh and smoosh map and
you all know what happened next
it was not clear that it was a joke and
some people got really upset and I think
we learned a lot from it I think other
people can speak better as to what
happened next I mean we had a tc39 those
three day meeting right after that that
event and I think all of our consensus
was like yes like we learned a lot from
this interaction they say certain things
that we can present you know certain
ways that we communicated with community
and it's unfortunate that happened but
we learned and hopefully we will never
do the same thing one thing that I
personally learned from this is that for
a lot of people it's not clear that tc39
is actually representing the developer
community as well in fact some people
are entirely just attending these
meetings only specifically to do that
and during smoosh gate it felt like
people felt like it was an
us-versus-them kind of thing which is
not the case at all so we should work on
clarifying that and there's definitely a
lot of work that we can do there but
we're trying I think that's actually a
huge thing that we
away from that was realizing that we
need to be more obvious about the fact
that we as individuals are involved in
tc39 because we are humans for people
where people who work on libraries with
people who work on websites for people
who work on browsers and and like we are
human beings who you know might make a
joke sometimes but because it's not
super obvious to the community that we
are doing what we're doing and who is
doing what we're doing it's pretty easy
to forget that it's just like some
nefarious council somewhere making the
rules that no one can attend so there's
a couple of people wondering like how do
they get involved like how does someone
who's new actually start talking to the
tc39 so we have all of our proposals on
the github tc39 in the repo organization
you can get involved in any one of the
proposals by opening issues by
commenting by trying to make sure your
use case is served or you can contribute
to Babel to actually get these things
implemented so that you can use them in
your code
and a related question to this is
someone asking about when writing up new
features like for example someone wants
to propose something where do you look
the most for inspiration are there other
languages and which ones or is it mostly
driven by requests from the community I
think it's a little bit of a combination
of both but what I personally find works
best is if it is to actually start with
a problem statement like there's a
certain problem that you want to solve
and then you motivate that problem
itself and then the solution can take
various shapes so at stage zero
especially you don't want to come up and
say oh I have this amazing solution to
this problem no you just want to say
look there is this problem do we agree
that this is a problem in JavaScript if
so then yes okay maybe we can go to
stage one and discuss solutions and
maybe you already taught up some
solutions but it's important to focus on
the problem rather than this one
specific solution to the problem so I
would like to up to that saying that
so again like there is a staging process
and there is a champion so usually it is
not like we meet and then say well
what's the problem in JavaScript
community what's like hard no somebody
already came up like I don't like this
syntax oh this is like source of my bug
like you know your proposal in like some
time about the erase and getting the
last item from array it was like you
know I constantly you know stumbled upon
the bug because of this I want to have
new features so I'm like proposing is
this a valid idea should we discuss this
and that's how things get into the
staging process so like like like you
missed it I'm like me I'm like a person
who is just going to teach a certain I'm
meeting as like representing like web
developer point of view and I don't go
to teach a certain I'm meeting because I
have something to propose like I'm more
like I want to listen to this
conversation to make sure that like our
views are reflected so I feel really
like inspired you know I'm in such a
like JavaScript Stockholm Syndrome that
I think it's fine nothing should be
changed and then every time the one of
these fine people says like I don't like
this or this is likely the unknowing and
I'm like ah it is annoying so I just say
today to the original question once we
have that problem statement and once we
figured out that we want to solve it
from there there is a combination of
taking inspiration from other languages
figuring out if there's like a more
JavaScript way to solve the problem so
it is a huge combination of all the
different ways we could approach it and
we don't we don't restrict ourselves to
any one route awesome thank you so the
next question is related to information
dissemination and like how do people
keep up with proposals specifically
where do you keep up with updates do you
have a website and another question is
how do you visually track all of the new
proposals through in the maturity stages
maybe with polyfill or a Babel plugin
and up until this point we've had a
github repository which was the tc39
proposals repository but we noticed
especially during smoosh gate
we had a bit of a communication problem
with the developer community it's hard
to find information about proposals and
what's going on
so what we've been doing for the last
little while is we've been working on I
hope this works
this isn't working okay and what we've
been working on
as a result is this project which also
doesn't work when I use my nose Oh
fascinating one second
undefined it's not a function everyone
can look at the fancy Mozilla dinosaur
and there we go that should work now oh
it doesn't fantastic let's try this one
next slide oh there we go sorry everyone
so we have built a website for the
community and this is what it looks like
and it's in beta it's something that
we're working on it's not complete but
what we would really love is to get
feedback from the community if this is
answering your questions and if this is
doing what it needs to do and if it's
not it would be great to have your
feedback and your comments and this
could be a great first step for people
who are interested in getting started
working with tc39 and contributing
hopefully this now works it doesn't work
whoops technically
NORs so I would like to say thank you to
the contributors who made this possible
within three months you can find the URL
there at the top if you want to visit it
and there is also a QR code here if you
just want to scan it so we are trying to
improve the information issue and namely
we are looking for feedback for this
beta version of a potential community
site so moving on from the website issue
and straight into the next section of
this which is just for fun we got a lot
of questions that were proposal specific
that we can answer rather quickly so
we're going to do a rapid-fire session
and let's do that with tc39 logo yeah
there we go nice so we're gonna have
three minutes and we're just gonna
answer these questions as quickly as we
can and if we missed your question
please come and say hi to us next to the
community lounge and within the next
three minutes when we wrap up so let's
go what are some of the most exciting
features coming next
optional training all right a couple of
people can answer that one I personally
love the matching pattern yeah pattern
matching is awesome
[Applause]
the church yes
excited about begins like finally
numeric like integers that make sense
and you can do arithmetic on them and
you won't get the wrong result that's
kind of amazing yeah okay moving on
what's your favorite JavaScript function
it's definitely flat right everyone's
favorite one is flat I'll aim up in
deduce not been reduced yeah okay so
this question is interesting local
storage between subdomains would be
awesome
not something tc39 is involved in this
is a Dom API and tc39 bailey is only
involved in the standardization of the
language sometimes it's hard to say what
exactly is language what isn't but in
this case it's about input/output and
that is not in the language at all so if
you had that question go chat with the
Dom API people and maybe they can help
you out next question how about a native
method for deep object cloning good idea
very complex the next one is similar
we'd love to have a non expensive non
library deep object compare the
comparison any hope on that again this
like come talk to us we we can go
through it you want to write that
proposal go for it what's the medium
turnaround for a proposal become reality
time wise do proposals follow the same
procedure well yes they follow the same
procedure but how long does it take
about some of them take years
I think minimum I saw was like 18 months
maybe if you're feeling really ambitious
maybe a year
I'd say the minimum the absolute minimum
would be one stage per meeting so maybe
you can do it in four meetings five
meetings eight to ten months but that's
it
there's no conflicts everybody's on
board and it just moves right along
another thing is that in order to
advance to stage four you need to
shipping implementations in browsers
which is not always in the control of
the champion or the author like unless
you go when I go and implement this in
two different JavaScript engines
yourself which is a lot of work on top
of all the work you're doing writing a
proposal then you'll just have to wait
until it happens basically and you can
help with that by already writing tests
and contributing tests to test two six
two for example so that these
implementations can just check if
they're correct or not easily but still
someone needs to do the work and
implement it we've got a couple of
seconds left can we use emojis in
function declarations please all right
now we can because emoji are not valid
identifiers if you google valid variable
name validator and Java scripts you'll
find a tool that I built exactly for
this purpose and we've got no time left
for one more question so please come and
say hi to us behind the next to the
community booth and we'd love to meet
all of you thank you